This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In a valley in central Slovenia, there's a giant limestone cave called Pekel, which means hell in Slovene. If you look hard at the rocks above the entrance, you can just make out the shape of the devil, which is one explanation for how the cave got its name. That is British expat and 99PI's Slovenia correspondent, Will Aspinall. I recently met up with Andrei Kapla from the Slovenian National Institute of Biology. Andrei studies the ecology of caves and today he is taking me spelunking. I'm not naturally inclined to go into caves.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。在中斯洛文尼亚的一个山谷里，有一个巨大的石灰岩洞穴叫佩克尔（Pekel），在斯洛文尼亚语中是“地狱”的意思。如果你仔细观察入口上方的岩石，你就能隐约辨认出魔鬼的形状，这也是该洞穴得名的一种解释。那是英国侨民兼 99PI 的斯洛文尼亚通讯员威尔·阿斯皮纳尔（Will Aspinall）。我最近见到了来自斯洛文尼亚国家生物研究所的安德烈·卡普拉（Andrei Kapla）。安德烈研究洞穴生态学，今天他要带我去洞穴探险。我天生就不太喜欢进洞穴。
Is it safe? It's completely safe. But there's one caveat in this case, because it was very, very rainy these days, and hopefully it didn't flood. But if it did flood, then we're in trouble. Okay, we're in the cave. The cave is narrow, only about a metre wide in places, but it's like 15 metres high. It's a chasm, and it's flooded. Oh, it's beautiful.
安全吗？完全安全。但这次有个前提，因为这几天雨下得非常非常大，希望没有被淹。但如果被淹了，那我们就麻烦了。好了，我们进洞了。洞穴很窄，有些地方只有一米左右宽，但大约有15米高。这是一个裂谷，而且被水淹了。哦，太美了。
Yeah, it is, but wet. You aren't scared of caves? Never was. Actually, I'm more comfortable in a cave than with people. Andrei and I are not exploring a cave called Hell just for fun. We're on a mission to catch an elusive insect that Andrei studies. A week earlier he left seven traps inside the cave and baited them with a special recipe. It is a nice mixture of beef liver, fish and gorgonzola. You put them in a vial and marinate them for a few days on sun. Absolutely disgusting. I'm trying to like these creatures.
是的，确实很美，不过很湿。你不怕洞穴吗？从来不怕。其实，我在洞穴里比跟人在一起更自在。我和安德烈探索地狱洞不仅仅是为了好玩。我们负有捕捉安德烈正在研究的一种难寻踪迹的昆虫的任务。一周前，他在洞穴里留下了七个陷阱，并用一个特殊的配方作为诱饵。这是一个由牛肝、鱼和戈贡佐拉奶酪组成的绝妙混合物。你把它们放在一个小瓶里，在阳光下腌制几天。绝对恶心。我正努力去喜欢这些生物。
It's easy, they're beautiful. The beautiful creature that we are looking for has only been found in five caves in the north of Slovenia. It's in a group of 51 known beetles called Anophthalmos, Greek for without eyes. These are not very big beetles, nothing special about them. More or less all look the same, so nothing special about the Beatles. Just the name is special. The Beatle is notorious because it is named after, arguably, the worst human being in history. We are hunting for Anophthalmus hitleri, more commonly known as Hitler's beetle.
很简单，它们很美。我们寻找的美丽生物只在斯洛文尼亚北部的五个洞穴中被发现过。它属于51种被称为 Anophthalmos 的已知甲虫群，在希腊语中意为“没有眼睛”。这些甲虫不是很大，没有什么特别之处。大体上长得都一样，所以这些甲虫本身没什么特别的。只有名字很特别。这只甲虫臭名昭著，因为它是以可以说是历史上最糟糕的人命名的。我们正在寻找 Anophthalmus hitleri，通常被称为希特勒甲虫。
Despite living in complete darkness in a handful of caves in a tiny central European country, this unremarkable insect is getting a lot of unwelcome attention right now. Hitler's beetle is at the center of a fierce debate raging in the usually polite worlds of botany and zoology. It's a debate about whether we should rename species that are named after objectionable human beings, and even whether we should be naming organisms after people at all. Plants and animals have no say over what we humans call them. But it turns out a controversial scientific name can profoundly impact how a species fares in the real world.
尽管生活在欧洲一个小国少数几个洞穴的绝对黑暗中，这种毫不起眼的昆虫现在却受到了大量不受欢迎的关注。希特勒甲虫正处于植物学和动物学这两个通常很文明的领域中一场激烈辩论的中心。这是一场关于我们是否应该给以令人反感的历史人物命名的物种重新命名，甚至我们是否应该用人名来命名生物的辩论。植物和动物无法决定我们人类如何称呼它们。但事实证明，一个有争议的学名可能会深刻影响一个物种在现实世界中的命运。
The practice of naming species after humans goes back to the 18th century in a man named Carl Linnaeus. Linnaeus was a really interesting character. So he was a Swedish botanist. Sandi Knapp is also a botanist and the author of In the Name of Plants, Remarkable Plants and the Extraordinary People Behind Their Names. He was a Swedish doctor actually, because in the 18th century, which is when Linnaeus lived, medicine was entirely based on plants.
以人类名字命名物种的做法可以追溯到18世纪的一位名叫卡尔·林奈（Carl Linnaeus）的人。林奈是一个非常有趣的人物。他是一位瑞典植物学家。桑迪·纳普（Sandi Knapp）也是一位植物学家，著有《以植物之名：杰出植物及其名字背后的非凡人物》（In the Name of Plants, Remarkable Plants and the Extraordinary People Behind Their Names）一书。实际上他是一名瑞典医生，因为在18世纪林奈生活的年代，医学完全是基于植物的。
He was also incredibly arrogant and he was convinced that he could just completely reform how we understood nature. Today his arrogance seems justified because he more or less met that lofty goal. Linnaeus found order in the chaos of the natural world by creating a new framework for naming and categorizing every known animal and plant. Before Linnaeus, the names of organisms were really more like sentences. So it would be a thing like, this is the plant that has white flowers with yellow bits in
他极其傲慢，坚信自己可以彻底改革我们对自然的理解。今天，他的傲慢似乎是合情合理的，因为他或多或少地实现了那个崇高的目标。林奈通过为每个已知的动物和植物创建命名和分类的新框架，在自然界混乱的秩序中找到了条理。在林奈之前，生物的名字实际上更像是句子。所以它会是这样一种东西：这是一种叶子边缘略有缺刻、花朵为白色且中心带有黄色斑点的植物。所以这会是植物的名字。
the middle and leaves which are slightly incised at the edges. So that would be the name of the plant. Linnaeus knew this was really cumbersome, and so he came up with a simpler naming convention. He gave every plant and animal a two-word name, in either Latin or Ancient Greek. To take a well-known example, Linnaeus called human beings Homo sapiens. The first word, Homo, meaning man, is a broad category, the genus. And then sapiens, which means wise or thinking, is the specific name, or the species. Together, the genus and species are combined to create a scientific name that's both unique
林奈知道这真的很笨重，于是他想出了一种更简单的命名惯例。他给每种动植物起了一个由两个词组成的名字，使用拉丁语或古希腊语。举个众所周知的例子，林奈将人类称为智人（Homo sapiens）。第一个词“Homo”意为“人”，是一个广泛的类别，即属（genus）。然后是“sapiens”，意为“明智的”或“有思想的”，是特定的名称，即种（species）。属和种结合在一起，创造出一个既独特又易记的学名。
and easy to remember. This became Linnaeus' binomial system, and over time, this concise piece of information design was picked up by scientists all across Europe. And I think it took off because essentially it replicates the noun adjective construction of things that we have in most languages. We have bicycles, which is the genus, and we have red bicycles and green bicycles and golden bicycles and little bicycles. But it wasn't inevitable that Linnaeus' binomial system would become the standard. At the time, there were lots of weird and, frankly, confusing alternatives. My favourite is one that was published in, I don't know, about 1760 by someone called
这就成为了林奈的二名法系统，随着时间的推移，这种简洁的信息设计被全欧洲的科学家所采纳。我认为它之所以流行，主要是因为它复制了我们在大多数语言中都有的“名词-形容词”结构。我们有自行车，这就是属，我们有红自行车、绿自行车、金自行车和小自行车。但林奈的二名法系统成为标准并非不可避免。当时，有很多奇怪且坦白说令人困惑的替代方案。我最喜欢的是大约在1760年左右由法国一个叫贝尔热雷（Bergeret）的人发表的一种方法。
Bergeret in France. In Bergeret's system, each letter of a plant's name corresponded to some aspect of its biology. The idea was that the name could communicate important information about the species, but it looked like a jumble of seemingly random letters. The name of the plant was the combination of those letters, so it was B, R, Q, X, W. You know, I just love it when the B, R, Q, X, W's are flowering in the spring. Is that easier to remember than a tropa belladonna for the deadly nightshade? And you can see why Linnaeus' system caught on.
在贝尔热雷的系统中，植物名字的每个字母都对应其生物学的一些方面。这个想法是，名字可以传达关于该物种的重要信息，但它看起来像是一堆看似随机的字母。植物的名字是这些字母的组合，所以它是 B, R, Q, X, W。你知道，我就是喜欢在春天盛开的 B, R, Q, X, W。这比用来指代颠茄的 Atropa belladonna 更容易记住吗？你能理解为什么林奈的系统会流行起来。
Linnaeus was also a brilliant teacher, and at Uppsala University just north of Stockholm, he inspired the brightest and bravest young men to go out and explore the natural world. They were called his apostles, but these were his students who basically went out, he sent them out around the world to collect plants in different parts of the world because at that time that was beginning to become possible.
林奈也是一位出色的老师，在斯德哥尔摩正北方的乌普萨拉大学，他激励了最聪明、最勇敢的年轻出去探索自然世界。他们被称为他的门徒，但这些基本上是他的学生，他把他们派往世界各地，在世界不同地区收集植物，因为在当时这开始成为可能。
His apostles traveled the world on dangerous scientific missions to Java and Japan, Venezuela and Vietnam. Many of them lost their lives to tropical diseases, and Linnaeus decided to honor their contributions to science by naming organisms after them. To use Stanley's analogy, not only were there red bicycles and yellow bicycles,
他的门徒们冒着危险的科学任务前往爪子和日本、委内瑞拉和越南。他们中的许多人死于热带疾病，林奈决定以他们的名字命名生物，以表彰他们对科学的贡献。用斯坦利的类比来说，不仅有红自行车和黄自行，现在也有威尔的自行车和罗曼的自行车了。
but there were now Will's bicycles and Roman's bicycles too. And it wasn't just his apostles. Linnaeus also named plants after scientists he admired. Take for example the magnolia. Pierre Magnol was a botanist who wrote a flora of the area around Montpellier and was one of the people who sort of first came up with the concept of plants having families, plants being in families. And Linnaeus was a great admirer of magnols, so he named Magnolia from Magnol.
而且不仅仅是他的门徒。林奈还用他钦佩的科学家的名字来命名植物。以木兰（magnolia）为例。皮埃尔·马格诺尔（Pierre Magnol）是一位植物学家，他写了一本关于蒙彼利埃周边地区植物区系的著作，并且是首先提出植物有科（families）、植物属于科这一概念的人之一。林奈非常钦佩马格诺尔，于是他用 Magnol 命名了 Magnolia。
But Linnaeus was clear that not just anyone should be given the honour of having a species or a genus named after them. He even wrote down guidelines about what type of person was acceptable. They weren't rules as in you had to follow them, but they were his rules for how things should be done properly. Things like names should not be used to gain the favour or preserve the memory of saints or of men famous in some other art. So his view was that you should name things for people who have promoted the science of botany.
但林奈明确表示，不应该随便把以自己名字命名物种或属的荣誉给任何人。他甚至写下了关于什么样的人才是可以接受的准则。它们不是必须遵守的规则，而是他关于如何正确行事的准则。诸如：名字不应用来博取圣人或在其他艺术中出名的人的青睐或保存他们的记忆。所以他的观点是，你应该用那些推动了植物学科学发展的人的名字来命名事物。
Linnaeus named 12,000 species in his lifetime, and actually very few of those were named after people. But in the centuries that followed, as more and more plants and animals got discovered, the practice became increasingly common. In Linnaeus' guidelines about what kind of people you should name a species after went more or less out the window. Increasingly, scientists began to name species after people they just happened to be fond of. Slovenia's infamous beetle was very nearly given a different name. The insect was discovered in 1932 by a Slovenian naturalist named Vladimir Khodrich in a cave very close to the one I visited with Andrei.
林奈一生命名了12,000个物种，实际上其中只有极少数是以人名命名的。但在随后的几个世纪里，随着越来越多的动植物被发现，这种做法变得越来越普遍。林奈关于应该以什么样的人命名物种的准则基本上被抛到了九霄云外。科学家们越来越开始用他们恰好喜欢的人的名字来命名物种。斯洛文尼亚臭名昭著的甲虫差点被赋予另一个名字。这只昆虫是1932年由斯洛文尼亚自然学家弗拉基米尔·科德里奇（Vladimir Khodrich）在离我和安德烈参观的洞穴非常近的一个洞穴中发现的。
Khodrich thought he had found a new species, but he wanted a second opinion. And so he sent a specimen to an Austrian beetle collector called Oskar Scheibel. Oskar Scheibel was actually very good entomologist. He had money, so he could afford to go to trips. He could afford to buy specimens from people like Mr. Kodric. And he had vast knowledge about this. Scheibel confirmed that the beetle was a new species.
科德里奇认为他发现了一个新物种，但他想要征求第二种意见。于是他将一个标本寄给了一位名叫奥斯卡·谢贝尔（Oskar Scheibel）的奥地利甲虫收藏家。奥斯卡·谢贝尔实际上是一位非常优秀的昆虫学家。他很有钱，所以他负担得起去旅行。他负担得起从像科德里奇先生这样的人那里购买标本。他对这方面有着渊博的知识。谢贝尔确认这只甲虫是一个新物种。
And adhering to Linnaeus's guidelines, he initially agreed to name the new beetle Anophthalmus Kudrychi to honor the discoverer. But then he had a radical change of heart, because in addition to being a world-famous bug collector... Unfortunately, he was a passionate Nazi. And so Scheibel's formal submission of Anaphthalmus Hitleri in a German scientific journal in 1937
为了遵循林奈的准则，他最初同意将这只新甲虫命名为 Anophthalmus kudrychi，以纪念发现者。但随后他的想法发生了彻底的转变，因为除了是一名世界著名的昆虫收藏家……不幸的是，他是一位狂热的纳粹分子。因此，谢贝尔于1937年在一家德国科学期刊上正式发表 Anophthalmus hitleri，将他的一生两大挚爱——昆虫学和阿道夫·希特勒结合在了一起。
combined his two great loves, entomology and Adolf Hitler. This part. The gentleman, the Chancellor of the Reich, Adolf Hitler, as an expression of my association to him. So he gives this species to Adolf Hitler as his devotion to him. Hitler was apparently quite tickled by this gesture. According to some sources, he sent a personal letter to Scheibel thanking him for the honor. Naming a species after Hitler might be particularly ill-advised,
这部分。这位绅士，帝国总理阿道夫·希特勒，作为我对他的联系的表达。因此，他将这个物种献给阿道夫·希特勒，以表达对他的忠诚。希特勒显然对这个举动感到很高兴。据一些消息来源称，他给谢贝尔写了一封私人信件，感谢他给予的荣誉。以希特勒的名字命名物种可能特别不明智，但这这种事情一直在发生。
but this kind of thing happens all the time. There are around 2 million known species in the world today. Each year, another 18,000 get discovered. And every new species needs a name. Which has led to some, shall we say, interesting choices? We did so much field work and went to so many different sites that, you know, that those first few months when we first started, we're like, oh, man, look, there's new species. We're really excited. But we just kept finding more and more and more. This is Derek Hennan. He's a diplodologist.
当今世界大约有200万个已知物种。每年又有18,000个被发现。每一个新物种都需要一个名字。这导致了一些，可以说是有趣的选择吗？我们做了那么多的实地考察，去了那么多不同的地方，你知道的，刚开始的头几个月，我们就像，哦，天哪，看，有新物种。我们真的很兴奋。但我们只是不断发现更多更多。这是德里克·海南（Derek Hennan）。他是一位倍足动物学家。
That's the person who studies millipedes. He's a diplodologist. That's the person who studies millipedes. In 2021 and 2022, Derek and two colleagues from Virginia Tech published several papers based on years researching the millipedes of Appalachia. Over that time, they discovered 50 new millipede species, and each one needed a name. When you have 50 new species to name, you're really trying to pull from anything to kind of make them unique and also just to sound different. They named some millipedes for the location where they were found, like Nenaria scholastica,
那是研究马陆的人。他是一位倍足动物学家。那是研究马陆的人。在2021年和2022年，德里克和来自弗吉尼亚理工学院的两名同事根据多年研究阿巴拉契亚马陆的成果发表了几篇论文。在那期间，他们发现了50个新的马陆物种，每一个都需要一个名字。当你需要给50个新物种命名时，你真的会试图从任何地方取材，让它们显得独特，同时也听起来与众不同。他们以发现它们的地点来命名一些马陆，比如 Nenaria scholastica，是在弗吉尼亚州华盛顿与李大学校园里发现的。
discovered on the campus of Washington and Lee University in Virginia. Others got names related to how they looked, like Nenaria serpens, a millipede with distinctly snake-like features. But with so many new millipedes, place names and simple adjectives wouldn't suffice. And so they decided to name some of them after people. And if you want an obscure millipede to stand out, why not name it after one of the most famous and beloved people on the planet? Yeah, well, first I would say, you know, I was just a fan of Taylor Swift's music
其他的则得到了与它们外表相关的名字，比如 Nenaria serpens，一种具有明显蛇类特征的马陆。但是面对如此多的新马陆，地名和简单的形容词已经不够用了。因此他们决定用人的名字来命名其中的一些。如果你想让一个晦涩难懂的马陆脱颖而出，为什么不以星球上最著名、最受喜爱的名人之一来命名它呢？是的，好吧，首先我想说，你知道的，我只是泰勒·斯威夫特音乐的粉丝，当我们开车去这些实地考察地点时，你知道的，只要有可能我就会播放泰勒·斯威夫特（Taylor Swift）的歌，所以，你知道的，某种程度上是为了向她的音乐致敬，它在我需要的时候保持了我的好心情。我想以她的名字命名一个物种。
and we'd be driving to these field sites and you know, I would like to play Taylor Swift when I could and so, you know, kind of as a nod to her music keeping me in a good mood when I needed it. I wanted to name a species after her. When Derek named a millipede, Nonariaaria swifti after the world's biggest pop star, he became perhaps the first diplodologist to be featured in the pages of Rolling Stone. Which was great because normally millipedes don't make front page news too often, so it was a fun experience. And I was just glad to have people excited about millipedes.
当德里克以这位世界最大流行歌星的名字将一种马陆命名为 Nanaria swifti 时，他或许成为了第一个登上《滚石》杂志页面的倍足动物学家。这太棒了，因为通常马陆不会太频繁地登上头版新闻，所以这是一次有趣的经历。我只是很高兴人们对马陆感到兴奋。
Taylor Swift wasn't the only human being Derek honored. Famous podcasters, the McElroy brothers, also have a millipede named after them. And crawling around at the bottom of Virginia's Blue Ridge Mountains is Nanaria Marianni, named after Derek's wife. My wife often goes out with me when I want to look for millipedes. And so that was also just to show her my appreciation for how patient she is goes out with me when I want to look for millipedes. And so that was also just to show her my appreciation for how patient she is to wait for me as I am digging around in the leaves. These days, lots of scientists are pulling stunts like this. There's a horsefly
泰勒·斯威夫特并不是德里克致敬的唯一人类。著名的播客麦克尔罗伊兄弟（McElroy brothers）也有一种以他们名字命名的马陆。在弗吉尼亚州蓝岭山脉底部爬行的是 Nanaria marianni，以德里克的妻子命名。当我想要寻找马陆时，我妻子经常和我一起出去。所以这也是为了向她表达我的谢意，感谢她在我四处翻找树叶时表现出的耐心。如今，许多科学家都在搞这样的噱头。有一种马头虻
named Scaptea bayansii and a tiny Mexican moth named Wackia chubaca. Arnold Schwarzenegger has two insects named after him, a beetle called Agra swartzeneggeri and a tiny fly with oversized legs called Mega propodiphora Arnoldi. And not all the names are cute and fun. Some scientists clearly have a political agenda. In 2005, entomologists Kelly Miller and Quentin Wheeler named a trio of slime mold beetles after Bush, Cheney and Rumsfeld.
被命名为 Scaptia beyansii，还有一只微小的墨西哥蛾子叫 Wockia chewbacca。阿诺德·施瓦辛格（Arnold Schwarzenegger）有两种以他名字命名的昆虫，一种叫 Agra schwarzeneggeri 的甲虫和一种腿部过大的微小苍蝇 Megapropodiphora arnoldi。并非所有的名字都可爱有趣。有些科学家显然有政治议程。2005年，昆虫学家凯利·米勒（Kelly Miller）和昆虫学家昆汀·惠勒（Quentin Wheeler）以布什、切尼和拉姆斯菲尔德的名字命名了一组黏菌甲虫。
Announced at the height of the Iraq War, it seemed like a subversive act. People thought they were slime mold beetles. He must be kind of making a joke about how awful these people are. No, no, no. Quentin was a great admirer of the Republican administration at the time. And so he named those beet Beatles to honor those men. My first instinct was that these names were mostly harmless. If hardworking zoologists want to shine a light on their relatively arcane work by naming a glow worm after their
在伊拉克战争最激烈的时候宣布，这似乎是一个颠覆性的举动。人们以为它们是黏菌甲虫。他一定是在开玩笑，讽刺这些人有多糟糕。不，不，不。昆汀当时是共和党政府的崇拜者。所以他用那些甲虫来纪念那些人。我的第一直觉是，这些名字大多是无害的。如果辛勤工作的动物学家想要通过以他们最喜欢的播客或政治家命名一只萤火虫来照亮他们相对晦涩难懂的工作，我又有什么资格去评判呢？
favorite podcaster or politician, who am I to judge? But sometimes a name is so loaded that it can cause very real problems for the unfortunate creature. Which brings us back to Hitler's Beetle. Twenty years ago, Andrei Kapler made a grim discovery in the cave where Anophthalmos hitlerii was first found. Poachers had destroyed the fragile cave ecosystem and the ground was littered with beetle traps. It turns out Hitler's beetle is in high demand from far right extremists who are buying up dead specimens
但有时一个名字承载了太多负荷，以至于会给这个不幸的生物带来非常现实的问题。这就把我们带回了希特勒甲虫。二十年前，安德烈·卡普拉在首次发现 Anophthalmus hitleri 的洞穴中做出了一个严峻的发现。盗猎者摧毁了脆弱的洞穴生态系统，地面上散落着甲虫陷阱。事实证明，希特勒甲虫备受极右翼极端分子的追捧，他们争相购买死标本，就像微小的纳粹战利品一样。
like tiny Nazi trophies. Every specimen is precious because we need it for research, not for showcasing them and boasting around, well look what I have, I have Hitler's beetle. That's stupid. Preserved insects have been pillaged from museums in Germany. And in December 2023, the New York Times reported that specimens of Hitler's beetle were going for as much as $2,000.
每一个标本都是珍贵的，因为我们需要它来做研究，而不是为了展示它们并四处炫耀，看我有什么，我有希特勒甲虫。那太蠢了。德国博物馆中保存的昆虫遭到了洗劫。2023年12月，《纽约时报》报道称，希特勒甲虫的标本售价高达2,000美元。
André believes that's a huge exaggeration and the real price is a fraction of that. But the poaching is definitely real. In 2004, the Slovenian government introduced a law to protect underground creatures like Anaphthalmos hitleri and the original cave was closed to the public. And while it's unlikely that Hitler's beetle will get poached to extinction by neo-Nazis, it's clear that the insect's terrible name is not making it any safer. OK, now the moment of truth.
安德烈认为这是一个巨大的夸大，真实价格只是其中的一小部分。但偷猎绝对是真实的。2004年，斯洛文尼亚政府出台了一项法律，以保护像 Anophthalmus hitleri 这样的地下生物，原始洞穴对公众关闭。虽然希特勒甲虫不太可能被新纳粹分子偷猎至灭绝，但很明显，这只昆虫糟糕的名字并没有让它变得更安全。好了，现在是见证时刻了。
André and I are back in the cave called Hell, and we're checking his beetle traps. OK, this is the first trap. This is the first trap. This is the first... Nothing? But sadly, we are striking out. Goddammit. Nothing. André says our struggles on today's beetle hunt have very little to do with neo-Nazis
安德烈和我回到了名为地狱的洞穴，我们正在检查他的甲虫陷阱。好了，这是第一个陷阱。这是第一个陷阱。这是第一个……什么都没有？但遗憾的是，我们一无所获。该死。什么都没有。安德烈说，我们今天捕捉甲虫的艰难过程与新纳粹分子几乎没有关系，
and everything to do with the heavy rainfall we've been getting. This one got flooded. OK, is that number five? Number five has got water in it. But the others were dry, just didn't have any of Hitler's beetle. OK. This is the last one the last one and it's empty
而跟我们最近遭遇的大量降雨息息相关。这个被淹了。好吧，那是五号吗？五号里面有水。但其他的都是干的，只是没有希特勒甲虫。好吧。这是最后一个，最后一个，它是空的。
does that surprise you? no no you have to be extremely patient with the cave beetles so it takes sometimes it takes years and years just to catch one so so it's not a, it's just misfortune. Coming up after the that the name Hitler's Beetle was an unfortunate historical relic, which begs the question, why not just change
这让你感到意外吗？没有，没有。你对洞穴甲虫必须极其有耐心，所以有时候需要数年时间才能捕捉到一只，所以这不是什么，这只是运气不好。接下来，希特勒甲虫这个名字是一个不幸的历史遗留物，这就引出了一个问题：为什么不直接改变它呢？
it? After all, it wouldn't be the first time. Shortly after World War II, Hitler's name was erased from roads and town squares all across Europe and beyond. Residents of Park Boulevard and Jopank, Long Island might be blissfully unaware that Nazi sympathizers once named it Adolf Hitler Street. So if we can take Hitler's name off street signs, why can't we remove him from the natural world?
毕竟，这不会是第一次。二战后不久，希特勒的名字从欧洲及其他地区的道路和城市广场上被抹去。长岛公园大道（Park Boulevard）和乔庞克（Jopank）的居民可能完全没有意识到纳粹同情者曾经将其命名为阿道夫·希特勒街。因此，如果我们能将希特勒的名字从路标上除名，为什么我们不能将他从自然界中移除呢？
It turns out that the international bodies that govern these matters are not big fans of change. The International Commission on Zoological Nomenclature, or ICZN, are responsible for the naming of animals. And they say that they have no power to change a name based on how offensive it is, a stance that's been getting a lot of heat in recent years. It's a remarkably controversial subject, far more controversial than I ever imagined. I've been publishing scientific articles for 30 years now, and this has got the most amount
事实证明，管理这些事务的国际机构并不热衷于改变。国际动物命名法委员会（ICZN）负责动物的命名。他们表示，他们无权根据一个名字有多冒犯来更改它，这一立场近年来受到了很多批评。这是一个非常具争议的主题，比我曾经想象的要争议得多。我已经发表了30年的科学文章，而这引起了人们最多的兴趣，超过了我发表过的任何东西。
of interest of anything that I've ever published. Richard Laidle is Professor of Conservation Science at the Federal University of Alagoas in Brazil. He was one of 11 scientists who co-authored an article in the journal Nature, Ecology and Evolution, arguing not only that offensive names like Anathalmas Hitleri should be changed, but we should also stop the practice of naming animals after humans entirely. Do you want a species to be a living reminder? Because that's what it is. It's a living reminder of something that maybe doesn't deserve to be celebrated.
理查德·莱德尔（Richard Ladle）是巴西阿拉戈斯联邦大学的保护科学教授。他是《自然·生态与进化》杂志上一篇由11位科学家共同署名的文章的作者之一，该文章不仅认为应该更改像 Anophthalmus hitleri 这样具有攻击性的名字，还认为我们应该彻底停止以人类名字命名动物的做法。你希望一个物种成为一个活生生的提醒吗？因为事实就是这样。它是对某种或许不值得被庆祝的事物的活生生的提醒。
Richard's main contribution to the paper was to provide some startling data. In Africa alone, a quarter of all vertebrates are named after people. And a large portion of these people are white British men and women from the 19th and early 20th centuries. Europe's grim legacy still grows, walks, flies and swims in the habitats of these once colonized lands. I remember going to London Zoo and seeing Lady Amherst's pheasant, which is just the most amazing looking bird. It's from China. You know, it could be the symbol of China. It's that amazing. It's one of the most beautiful birds in the world, named after a posh English woman. To Richard, the morality of this is pretty clear, but before the paper had even gone out,
理查德对这篇论文的主要贡献是提供了一些惊人的数据。仅在非洲，四分之一的脊椎动物都是以人的名字命名的。而其中很大一部分人是19世纪和20世纪初的白人英国男女。欧洲严峻的遗产仍在这些曾被殖民的土地的栖息地中生长、行走、飞翔和游泳。我记得去伦敦动物园时看到了金鸡（Lady Amherst's pheasant），那是看起来最令人惊叹的鸟。它来自中国。你知道的，它可能是中国的象征。它是如此惊艳。它是世界上最美丽的鸟类之一，以一位时髦的英国女性的名字命名。对理查德来说，这背后的道德问题非常清晰，但在论文发表之前，
he was already getting the sense that not everyone in the scientific community agreed with him. One of the heads of his institution even urged him not to publish. One of the heads of his institution even urged him not to publish. At which time I started to panic, because then I realized that the s*** was really going to hit the fan. When the article finally came out in March 2023, many of his peers were outraged. I was totally stunned how passionate some taxonomists were against this idea. The main argument against Richard's proposal is maintaining scientific continuity. Right now, the ICZN will only change names if further research causes the status of an animal to be revised, from say, a subspecies to a full species.
他就已经感觉到科学界并非所有人都同意他的观点。他的一位机构负责人甚至敦促他不要发表。他的一位机构负责人甚至敦促他不要发表。就在那时我开始感到恐慌，因为我意识到事情真的要闹大了。当这篇文章最终在2023年3月发表时，他的许多同行感到愤怒。我对一些分类学家对这个想法的反对如此激烈感到完全震惊。反对理查德提议的主要论点是保持科学的连续性。目前，只有在进一步的研究导致动物的地位发生修正（例如从亚种修正为完整物种）时，ICZN 才会更改名字。
They're conservative about change because they don't want to disrupt the chain of scientific knowledge that goes all the way back to Linnaeus. For Richard, that feels like an excuse for inaction. He says that too often, scientists regard themselves as being above politics. The fundamental aspect of this, that naming something is a political act and, you know, pretending that it isn't is not particularly intellectually honest. And for any political act, we need to think about the potential consequences, not just now, but in the future. At the very least, Richard thinks scientists should
他们对改变持保守态度，因为他们不想破坏可以追溯到林奈的科学知识链。对理查德来说，这感觉像是无所作为的借口。他说，科学家们往往认为自己凌驾于政治之上。这其中的根本方面是，命名某事是一个政治行为，你知道的，假装它不是在知识上并不是特别诚实。对于任何政治行为，我们需要考虑潜在的后果，不仅是现在，还有未来。至少，理查德认为科学家应该
challenge themselves to get more creative and specific when naming new species. If you have to name 200 new species, that's difficult. Yeah, but it's not that difficult. Get a map out. There are ways to do this. Crowdsource it. Use local words. Use local landmarks.
挑战自己在命名新物种时变得更有创意和更具体。如果你必须命名200个新物种，那是很困难的。是的，但这并没有那么难。拿出一张地图。有办法做到这一点。众包它。使用当地的词汇。使用当地的地标。
There's countless possibilities. Richard is not short of ideas. And throughout our lively Zoom call, I have to say he made a convincing advocate for change. Yeah, I really feel we ought to give a bit more respect to nature and especially when we're naming it. But botanist Sandy Knapp is not totally convinced by Richard Ladle's proposal. She believes that changing all the species that are named after people would be a monumental undertaking. There are thousands of names of things that are named for people, thousands and thousands. And it's not like there's one master spreadsheet that you can just edit one time and be done with. Sandy says that going through and trying to change all those names in the countless places they appear would be extremely time consuming and an unnecessary
有无数的可能性。理查德并不缺乏想法。在我们生动的 Zoom 通话中，我必须说他是一个令人信服的变革倡导者。是的，我真的觉得我们应该对自然给予更多尊重，尤其是在我们给它命名的时候。但植物学家桑迪·纳普（Sandy Knapp）并不完全被理查德·莱德尔的提议说服。她认为，更改所有以人名命名的物种将是一项艰巨的任务。有成千上万个以人命名的东西的名字，成千上万。而且并不是说有一个总电子表格，你可以只编辑一次就大功告成了。桑迪说，通读并试图在它们出现的无数地方更改所有这些名字将极其耗时，并且会分散人们对更紧迫问题的注意力，是不必要的干扰。
distraction from much more pressing concerns. Time is a resource and there's way more important things to do than changing all the names. I mean, we're in the middle of a planetary emergency and a biodiversity crisis. And so do we want to find out more about biodiversity and how to preserve it and restore it? Or do we want to spend our time changing the names of things? To me, that's the choice.
时间是一种资源，有比更改所有名字更重要的事情要做。我的意思是，我们正处于星球紧急状态和生物多样性危机的中心。所以我们是想了解更多关于生物多样性以及如何保护和恢复它的信息？还是想把时间花在更改事物的名字上？对我来说，这就是选择。
Currently, the ICZN have no appetite for taxonomical revolution, but the ICN or the International Code of Nomenclature for Algae, Fungi and Plants has recently removed some offensive names. And although she isn't a fan of Richard's radical proposal, Sandy Knapp proudly officiated those changes at the 2024 International Botanical Congress in Madrid.
目前，ICZN 对分类学革命没有兴趣，但国际藻类、真菌和植物命名法法规（ICN）最近删除了一些具有攻击性的名字。尽管她不是理查德激进提议的粉丝，但桑迪·纳普自豪地在马德里举行的2024年国际植物学大会上主持了这些更改。
Sandy Knapp, Director, National Botanical Congress of Madrid And one of the proposals that was voted in is to take all of the species names which are based on the epithet, Kaffra. Kaffra is derived from a word that is a racial slur in South Africa. And that, for me, is actually important to recognize that that's something that needs to be changed. It's very, very offensive. It's offensive to a group of people. All of those names were changed. We take the C away, and they become Afra.
桑迪·纳普，马德里国家植物学大会主任。在被投票通过的提案中，有一项是删除所有基于加弗拉（Kaffra）加词的物种名称。Kaffra 源于南非的一个种族侮辱词汇。对我来说，实际上重要的是认识到这是需要改变的东西。这非常非常具有攻击性。它对一群人具有攻击性。所有这些名字都改变了。我们去掉 C，它们就变成了 Afra。
To do this, the Congress exploited a loophole that allows scientific names to be corrected if they are misspelled. It gave delegates an opportunity to vote for this one specific change without committing to some groundbreaking new position on naming more broadly. Everyone was very respectful, you know, well if they weren't respectful I would have kicked them out. But they were very respectful. And then we ran it, I ran it as a secret ballot. So there was a, so you just wrote yes or no on your bit of paper and put it in a box. And then it was counted and it was 63%.
为了做到这一点，大会利用了一个漏洞，允许在科学名称拼写错误时对其进行修正。这给代表们提供了一个机会，可以投票支持这一项具体的更改，而无需对更广泛的命名做出某种开创性的新立场。每个人都非常尊重，你知道的，如果他们不尊重，我就会把他们踢出去。但他们非常尊重。然后我们进行了投票，我把它作为无记名投票进行。所以有一个，所以你只需在你的纸条上写是或否，然后把它放进盒子里。然后进行了统计，结果是 63%。
It was an historic moment. For the first time since Linnaeus came up with his binomial system, the offensive names of more than 200 plants, fungi and algae were changed. As for Anophthalmos hitleri, I was surprised to learn that Andrei is actually not all that concerned about the name. It's just a name for me. For me it's important what kind of animal it is, where it lives, what it does, what it is, its position in ecology and everything.
这是一个历史性的时刻。自林奈提出二名法以来，首次有200多种植物、真菌和藻类的具攻击性名称被更改。至于希特勒甲虫，我很惊讶地发现安德烈实际上并不怎么关心这个名字。对我来说它只是一个名字。对我来说重要的是它是什么动物，它在哪里生活，它做什么，它是什么，它在生态学中的地位以及一切。
Andrei was more interested in the beetle itself. I wasn't able to see one alive, but he had some dead Anophthalmos hitlery specimens he wanted to show me at his lab in Ljubljana, the Slovenian capital. Inside, he pointed to five tiny insects pinned neatly in a row, the color of aged bronze. So if you can see, it's a small, unremarkable, nothing to see actually, just a small beetle. Some people say, oh, it's just an ant, but it's not, it's a beetle.
安德烈对甲虫本身更感兴趣。我没能看到活的，但他在卢布尔雅那（斯洛文尼亚首都）的实验室里有一些死去的 Anophthalmus hitleri 标本想让我看。在里面，他指着五只整齐地排成一排的微小昆虫，颜色像陈旧的青铜。所以如果你能看到，它是一只很小的、不起眼的、实际上没什么可看的甲虫，只是一只小甲虫。有人说，哦，它只是一只蚂蚁，但它不是，它是一只甲虫。
Under a microscope, it was possible to see their slender, almost elegant features. Andrei says that the beetle evolved after an ancient ice age when living above ground became impossible. They couldn't live anymore in the soil, in the gravel or whatever. So they moved underneath. And looking at this creature close up, you can appreciate how it evolved
在显微镜下，可以看到它们纤细、几乎优雅的特征。安德烈说，这只甲虫是在一次古代冰河时期之后进化的，当时在地面生活变得不可能。它们再也不能在土壤、砾石或其他地方生活了。所以它们移到了地下。近距离观察这个生物，你可以欣赏它是如何进化以适应永久黑暗中的生活的。
to suit a life in perpetual darkness. If you live in a cave, you don't need ice, it's just waste of energy to produce ice and they don't have pigment. The colour of them is brownish yellow. Hitler's beetle escaped from the worst conditions nature could throw at it. It adapted and thrived in a new underground environment where it lived out the next two million years.
如果你住在洞穴里，你不需要冰，产生冰只是浪费能量，而且它们没有色素。它们的颜色是褐黄色。希特勒甲虫逃脱了自然界能施加的最糟糕条件。它在一个新的地下环境中适应并繁衍生息，并在那里度过了接下来的两百万年。
That's amazing, so two million years of life and then in the last, you know, less than a hundred years, it's named after the worst human in history. Yeah. Well, it's not its fault. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Will Aspinall, produced and edited by Emmett Fitzgerald, mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real, fact checking by Graham Hayesha. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube,
太棒了，两百万年的生命，然后在过去的，你知道的，不到一百年的时间里，它以历史上最糟糕的人的名字命名。是的。好吧，这不是它的错。本周的《99%隐形》由威尔·阿斯皮纳尔（Will Aspinall）报道，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）制作和剪辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martin Gonzalez）混音，音乐由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）创作，格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Hayesha）核实事实。凯茜·图（Cathy Tu）是我们的执行制片人，库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Kolstad）是数字总监，德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁布（Chris Berube）、
Jason De Leon, Chris Verjonsson, Vivian Lay, Lash Madon, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleason, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of the logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California.
杰森·德莱昂（Jason De Leon）、克里斯·韦尔容森（Chris Verjonsson）、维维安·莱（Vivian Lay）、拉什·马顿（Lash Madon）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、凯利·普莱姆（Kelly Prime）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森（Jacob Medina Gleason）以及我，罗曼·马斯。99%的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。我们是 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。加利福尼亚州奥克兰市住宅区，美丽。
You can find us all on Blue Sky, which is kind of like Twitter, but for people who don't think things should be named after Nazis, we're also hanging out on our own Discord server. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你们都可以在 Blue Sky 上找到我们，这有点像推特，但适合那些认为不应该以纳粹命名事物的人，我们也在自己的 Discord 服务器上闲逛。那里有一个链接，以及 99PI 过去每一集的链接，网址是 99PI.org。这一集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。